my name is nine changa I'm later in
chief of your language we are delighted
to have with us in our Studios President
Ronald de borracha the president of
African Development Bank Group second
time Pacific and you'd like to have us
at you you have be in this business of
development for a long time you are mr.
finance one love you brought some
tremendous changes to their country and
now as president of the African
Development Bank you have responsible
for a much larger area development after
start with a figure has 600 million
hectares of uncultivated land it could
become the works for darling so what is
preventing Africa from developing that
potential well he you know Almirola
teaching he is always the foundation for
transiting from low income to the income
that is true for asia-based like China
and Japan Vietnam and many others so
you're right let's increase in
productivity Russia there's a jobs be
created as ocean begin to join the
global of America value chains see
everyone at home but it takes more than
simply land
who missed the green revolution and now
what a quality measures and shredded
with an increased our productivity in
the 80s and 90s they are a shoe with a
macroeconomic policies which favored
oven worlds you know although these
generates over taxation of farmers
wasn't for systems by infrastructure
that has been corrected now in take
measures on the supply side things like
infrastructure water management more
than seeds better technologies so I
think important things are underway but
in my judgment it all begins with sound
infrastructure better support farmers
and diminishing the post-harvest losses
it was some countries even when food has
been produced forty percent of its lusts
how long he harvests from it was a quite
interest rate so in other words lack of
roads for transportation to April
innocently where housing transportation
and so on and all this is resolved by
the infrastructure ensuring with
mancinos convert the Libyan though some
teachers have been with extremely
interesting it has been the use of
mobile phone technology for farmers
access market information also the
increasing use of community exchanges
agricultural with exchanges for price
discovery these two things i have been
on see increasing am proficient in some
ways infrastructure communication
infrastructure helping your culture so
you have had infrastructure roads with a
system then the information
infrastructure well mobile phone system
and by the virtual community exchanges
so getting you and one more example how
this mobile telephone infrastructure is
helping all right imagine if Alma in
there Reuters so he has no harvests of
tomatoes of dangers and so talk [ __ ]
they can curl their produce to the
market or you can wait for collectors
gum and buys but the chances are this
family does not know the price but with
the mobile phone they will exactly with
the market prices engage marketed
products market so they will calculate
the issues of arbitrage so the villa men
don't collect most direct it has been
it's too important in increasing which
are the countries which have done this
more Kenya is originals Kenya salida but
others are following year as well but
Kim has been supplying church and
vegetable stew Europe for some time
right it's one of the countries where
farmers did our journey through
evolutions melon floriculture and
horticulture and also all serious the
history of that but in another country
is a fabulous what you can use me the
other issue is the Africa's nasad
deserve a wild Africa's oil reserves
starting at neuron it amounts to almost
half of saga
and yet continue like Nigeria can't even
produce enough electricity for its own
use so what is again what is the cost
for this look it has an important point
taps one let me see what I'm finds in
Africa stop whether it is oil natural
gas for some other minerals absolutely
have to figure out this time other it
straight in terms of using the rent to
bring it infrastructure in destiny land
development but also to as you prepare
one won't waste some of that energy that
we need what was it that was missing the
police are among the voice any
environment then living environment now
it is jelly and things are we in trouble
last year which I mention how is
beginning and make it for me the energy
sector and I think the mistakes made in
the past's one lane from it so the
question of infrastructure how does the
bank have country one of the mechanisms
in which your organization can help new
your African countries to develop
infrastructure no African is a gun he
needs every about not even about now
from all sources available who can raise
maybe filter to milanos so this data so
the first thing we need to figure out is
how to feel back it was public sources
and edited so that's facing one to
figure out with governments can [ __ ] you
the second thing is how to make it
possible for the private sector to bring
capital into the infrastructure yeah
things like energy as they have done on
optic fibres severely cables and I team
you know want to attract independent
power producers but for that rock you
need illegal to from yeah police if
availability spend a second meet so fill
the gap look for innovative voice
figured out bring in rabbit capital
infrastructure and that Lee well very
keen to promote but accelerates the
development of Africa's single market so
original infrastructure files bad boy
whether it is transport corridors well
that is all fools whether it is a trade
facilitation all those things country
was a member infrastructure is not an
end in itself yeah it's a Midland end
which is trade movement of goods people
and services yeah so it is in trying to
attract private capital infrastructure
you have to order you set a good liberal
restructure and enforcement of
regulations and that means the question
of government's dirty so you have to
have because so much of African
resources have been spirited away by
poor governance and corruption and how
does the bank deal with that issue go
there with me tell about ? resources it
is true that lack of transparency level
in the oil and gas sector has been a
challenge for thurs and we are dealing
with that when increasing transparency
accountability among the intervention by
this second hidden face which were not
know isn't African I'm doing getting the
real value of its resources sometimes
contracts I lopsided so that is
production-sharing whether the royalty
is already Alejandro taxation comics did
not get a fair share over hoes do today
because of management models of the
extractive industry than to has to
change thirdly it's about getting a bit
of volume so exporting them their proper
someone was mentioned today in mineral
or the coltan which is a girl from
Colombo tantalite cell phones now in all
education don't press the cotton and now
who sells phones you don't get the value
so will you take me to the value of
those minerals and some familiar three
things I will let it get accountability
transparency number two there doesn't
show these contracts management or
direct certainly let us get more value
from auto materials it's like setting
our pair oil Frank Africa doesn't have
already from right then common
refineries Bassam them already broke a
passage whatever to see will be sharing
development
infrastructure resources reply plans
their families because often you have
two neighboring countries it's covering
large amounts of a select column was a
big that Jack was huge amount of
infrastructure but the source is owned
orphan amount of the GT w yeah so
putting the sausage we better for all of
them from negotiation to value and which
is mentioned so they appeared a lot of
reports about Chinese building
infrastructure is that infrastructure
built essentially for Chinese extractive
industry or is it for general use
there's a lot of misunderstanding on
this one mostly Chinese if they call the
energy markets attacking Brazil India
another's the total amount of managers
come to infrastructure 25 million bones
now by I assume that channel is pops
leading about the games of the Chinese
news is that there will fall for him gas
or mineral and we were looking for
infrastructure so make it it mega do we
save the oil you put the money makes
account you pay the chance they bring
the engineers equipment that we always
margin ports airports have it it is much
better than the past models whatever
works the money the country they
appreciate the exchange rate of the
Dutch disease progression destroyed now
owned by the way of getting what you
want jeez can you go rent from oil into
infrastructure in the changes was
getting all ready for for the industry
if you catch this son
the Chinese are also trying to give some
land to grow crops I'm done that on some
of that what I know that we work up
investment analysis from diverse from
Europe per gallon per team no other
business is done in other countries but
this thing could land globe we just
think is a very fun it's not the
china-africa problem to my knowledge
they don't think sometimes is blown up
about proportions because water before
is investment in a professor so your
oath ceremony second time have to be
away from my visa because of security
issues so the security issue how big an
obstacle it is developing an African
tree it's not security for such much of
a festival I've said 19 to pass on the
webcast in the novel Monday eight
percent were sometimes you have peace
keeping forces from the nominations or
from balcony know how much more festive
what is actually happening is that there
are so many changes team-best Africa
demographics organization Natural
Resources young people dashboard all
these other bodies forces condemned
evolution is the same physics albert
centrifugal forces results and rip it
off horses and other things off to
manage so often there is a slippage it
becomes security problem this is also
done in the son of a nobleman it takes a
stolen election it takes a voice a
transition it takes some other political
problem it exploded this what happened
in the case of the air becomes
those a difficult transition then I was
in give them take over the nose then
take it all classes so the bank had will
hit or some other country just amazing
yeah just to salute six years into our
rotation those in version 2 news as well
yes because again of issues of
mismanagement of the economic system and
the politics yeah but overall you think
that I figure is my ex way doesn't it
know there's no controversy there
there's no Congress because what is
driving the current momentum basically
trainings it is increased investment
firm direct investment it is growing
domestic or something and then now the
policy environment is getting strong
it's from every day so anything the
benefits the tendency to think that what
is that big knife Raqqah is only a
function of commodity prices that is one
of the factors so I don't think that the
stronger projections for this year 6 1
percent when we maintained some country
like Nigeria would be even more I
suspect well the big risk is uh not his
mission to you his chain force of change
on the political social scene lack of
jobs in young people lack of inclusion
which occurred so much frustration and
potential for explosion that is very
very helpful and thank you so much
appreciate
No